all right pogchamp you've probably seen
this dude's face when something hyper
surprising happens on stream but who the
hell is this guy and where did he come
from
well back in 2010 cross-counter TV
released a blooper reel between longtime
socal street fighter bros ryan gootecks
Gutierrez and mike ross in the video
this happened okay
youtubers loves you Texas unexpected
expression to the off-camera incident
but no labels managed to accurately
describe it stank
a year later goo Texan Ross released a
promo for a Mad Catz Fight Stick using
their goofy brand of humor and a random
game of vlogs
you know gootecks pogs let's play Mike
Ross gootecks would stomp Ross using an
ingenious technique pong champion the
term pogchamp was full and gradually
attach itself to do tech now iconic
space I remember I talked with Ryan
recover a good time not like no man oh
is that your face and you like what are
you talking about fighting game
community fully embraced the media and
in no time it spreads through the
internet via 4chan and steam strangely
becoming the face of Team Fortress 2
raffles
it wasn't long before pogchamp was added
to twitch chat where today it is still
one of the site's most used emails but
pond champs influence has extended even
beyond gaming becoming part of everyday
conversation find out your mom name
lasagna for dinner
pogchamp they're making a sequel to your
favorite movie pogchamp finding out
you're not the father
definitely pod check gootecks responded
favorably to the internet community's
response to its faith partisan the power
of pogchamp to build and develop his
personal brand i get some swag levels
while gootecks has become renowned for
his amusing facial expressions over the
years none have been able to generate
the community response and reactionary
means of pogchamp and although all the
memes manners and talented people out
there and so in this trip down memory
lane
i'm josh brewery and that was panchak
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button